welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham Aziz and today
I'm joined by Sean Taylor who is a team
manager at a recruitment business called
premier group and Sean currently manages
a team of 11 and all of these people
recruit into the IT sector Sean thank
you for joining me
cheers mate thanks family and I think
we'll start with as soon as you're you
chat that used to work for you max you
said yes who put his in touch I'm
looking forward to smack spoke very
highly of them are there I know so yeah
so as obvious a man as you know and what
we was talking about where I always like
to start is how did Sean Taylor into the
world of recruitment mate let's start
there yeah I would say semi fell into it
semi try to get into it okay
once University did what everyone does
at University Business criminology just
something to wasn't do it unit business
criminology I looked up cordon ology and
then I was like nah yeah should have
done it and rolled out of that the job
market is pretty good that have been
about 2007 I think
yeah decided to go travelling for a year
I caught himself out I'll get a job when
I come back towards the end of traveling
you start hearing murmurs that there's a
recession hit in I was in Australia at
the time and it some decent money yeah
recession what's this comeback that long
list of jobs on you know milk grounds
and all those other websites with all
those were cream and cream jobs with all
those graduate jobs it completely
disappears so I was in for a bit of a
shock
luckily my father say luckily and he got
me into door-to-door sales for about six
weeks really talking needs a job really
yeah I've been applying for jobs for I
don't know three four weeks and he was
just saying look you can talk get
yourself out there knock on doors you've
only got to make one you know
generate a couple of leads and if
something turns to money six seven
hundred quid which at the time I was
keen to do didn't really realize that
knocking on 7,200 doors each day before
window so even worse yeah it's good that
definitely is installed some of them
yeah about serious grant yeah anywhere I
got out of that very quickly so about
sitting about six months and then I went
into a call center I wanted something
with a base salary yeah a sanity and
what would you sell in it was now it's a
course and it was yeah for a Viva that
should insurance yeah it was it was hard
graft for bringing up from certain
locations saying you know other ounces
collapsing yeah anyway did that and then
I jumped into a NVQ based organization
that were selling apprenticeships in sir
companies okay so you know do you want
somebody to pay somebody three pound 20
an hour all you've got to do is let a
Natori an Assessor come in once every
two weeks and they can gain a
qualification I did that for about six
to seven months mmm but it's hard graft
you're working with people are looking
to get into that sexy had higher dropout
rates the Commission was next to nothing
obviously because it was
government-funded mmm someone said I'd
be good at recruitment and yeah he said
that a couple of people that's
completely blind so d start looking to
sort go into it yeah so I booked off a
couple of days went down to the
Berkshire area and spent a day of
interviewing with a set of company's
records user x-ray
yeah the age old you go into a
rectangular hands I've got a clue what's
going on next thing I know I'm being be
stood to high heaven yeah no sell me a
pen do me you must have been like the
again the perfect candidate though yeah
yeah door-to-door says cool Center what
why hello sir why are you wearing a
black tie so me this pen you got you had
all that yeah you bet you you're not
going to a funeral why you
that do you top like everything it's not
right now I'm gonna send you out to four
clients
mm-hmm I'm there shaking thinking right
okay I'll go to four interviews now and
yet clearly didn't get any the job sir
no no he was this guy was pumping me to
some of the recruitment companies then
who were clearly still doing very well
and they I dropped up with this
apprenticeship experience selling
obviously the threats record probably
said I've got recruitment experience
yeah and then throw me in and expected
me said to make out like I'm building
some sort of money when I wasn't so that
didn't go particularly well but I'm
still keen to give it another guy's what
came down for a second I spent a couple
of hours premiere didn't think anything
of it cuz my confidence was shot and
then yeah a phone call the following
Monday and as in like just interviewed
with premier and then well I came down I
interviewed with them and a couple of
other companies but I'd be lying if I
said that the first that first day I
went for interviewing whatever was a
couple of weeks before that you know
that bat played his toll on me in terms
of or taking his whole in terms of I
didn't always get myself into a 40-bit
one last go because I'm yeah and then
there you go when I'm at weekends and
for well that's that that's that's me
knocked on the a debate go back to my
job and I am pretend like nothing's
changed
yeah and then luckily I got a phone call
saying can you start in two weeks you
better find a place to live and come
move dance Berkshire well and use moving
from where place called Boston in
Lincolnshire so yeah yeah very much so
nice mate and then so then obviously
ever since then you've been a premier
for nine years this month Ashley that's
amazing yeah generally I think I've sat
down with a lot of people recently that
have been in one recruitment company for
a long time and I think honestly in
today's world of looking for jobs and
always one in the next best thing and
all that I think that's a great
achievement particularly recruitment
might like 9 years in one McCrimmon
business is like 30 years in
yeah and especially as we've evolved
with the industry as well you know I've
been at 1:1 recruitment company premiere
but it's like I've changed you know 2 or
3 times I've gone with them on their
journey
yeah yes so what you what you did you
join premiere 2011 2011 ok cool
so then just to frame mark them for
everyone listen and you've you've been
on that typical route of join there's a
consultant and then climbed up the ranks
of how did it go like senior consultant
principle or what was the typical what's
the route that you've been down yes he
start off as a rookie obviously spends I
think back then because I wanted people
on the phones pretty quickly it was two
weeks resourcing long they managed to
make a placement when to it 9i they're
contributing to found the candidate yeah
contributed towards a placement there's
a resources so that probably got me a
man completed it to find candidates yes
they can lovely we get 1 5 no they can't
what's the purpose no so did that and
and then obviously bill I what I was
into a rookie recruiter then got from a
sign-off and then it was yeah senior
consultant lead consultant team lead and
now team manage every mother yeah 11
people yes yeah and have you always been
in the same sort of sector yeah I've
always been night II did a couple years
in development around nets to Microsoft
and then I moved over to infrastructure
and then later into DevOps okay
that's interesting yeah so and then up
it so then I think we just chatted
before but just to help me out as well
before we sort of start unpacking this
like like the majority of those nine
years and have you always build Oh yep
until four three four months ago
okay so predominate build yeah and then
slowly but surely obviously again in
more and more management
responsibilities to where now it's like
your roles to get the most out of the
people around you yeah yeah first of all
months then they're like really how and
you know fresh got the job first day
rocker but I think it was half nine five
cases
and you finished it high five
the manager taps you on the shoulder and
goes off tomorrow officer that was
because user induction can you get
yourself in for sort of I think it was
eight o'clock yeah so I've Drive back to
my mates dad's house while staying on
his sofa um okay I call it eight o'clock
now okay I can deal with that and then
you know Lambie old goes from 8 o'clock
so rather than half five-year there till
6:00 after 6:00 and yeah and listen to
one of your podcasts leave them recently
about someone you know if you'd have
said if you'd look back and said look if
you'd have told me at the start of taken
X Y Zed to get you where you needed to
be you know you know tough old things go
yeah I'll do that again yeah you know
the first 12 probably even longer the
first 12 to 15 months was hard graft
really and really putting the work
effort yeah what the what putting the
work in
I've always been a big believer in which
offices change over time because I've
matured
but the more work you the more effort
you put in and we're gonna get the more
you're gonna get out but as we know it's
not just about always that's about
working smart as well yeah yeah so okay
cool why don't why didn't you quit then
even being honest I don't want to be
classed as a failure yeah and I'd moved
down from living with my parents to
amazed that sofas not much even up great
yeah yeah you went all-in right yeah
didn't want to go like back then what I
was 22 23 to start a little bit later
that's what a lot some people do
I didn't want to go back home and it
makes that I was you know I've tried
something and it hasn't worked later in
life you know I promote people try and
thinks if it doesn't work that's no it's
great don't worry but back then I just
was like no I'm this is going to this is
going to work
yeah and so those first 1215 months and
they were really difficult was it so
literally after two weeks was you then
trying to get crying was it a 360 rock
yeah 360 obviously from from week to
week free yeah you you give him quite a
lot of training in terms of what to do
but yeah it was here's a couple of
clients to be getting on with but they
were the scraps get just to make you
know keep you interested there's that
there's the database go at it and go and
gone because how big were premier
that because I'll see they're big
because they well that's a good question
there's probably about forty fifty
really something bad about twenty five
an hour
what about forty to fifty in terms of
consult and there's a good amount of
people in reading where you was bad yeah
I mean I joined a pretty small team that
I assume the recession had probably
taken over taking hold of I joined the
team a lot four or five but then on the
engineering team there was sort of seven
eight nine yes you probably probably
look about 30 to 35 me I was actually
looking back at it what did you burn
your first year me 60 K was it
absolutely nothing really and he was our
craft
really yeah just focused on all the
wrong things was the biggest challenge
in those first 1215 months I mean do you
say I changed my mindset changing my
mindset a mother of yeah I'd do all the
things that rookies and people new into
the business would do I'd overwork the
wrong roles opening means salt I would
be yes sir no sir three bags full so in
terms of that's big that when you
realize that yeah you know there's been
not being a yes-man you know get off the
phone to a client and and I you know the
first person you spoke to in about sixty
calls it was clearly it was it was four
hours day 100 dance by lunch that sort
of scenario straight off the bat you
know you got a few points you imagine
I've got a job absolute no quality to be
qualified yeah I'm just happy I've been
given a job may absolutely a puzzling I
gotta fill it yes definitely what is it
is a gradual it's not grad season
shortened don't worry I'll find
something so if you do it was only three
and a half grand for friends yeah it
took me a long while to realize that if
you got to do you gotta do it properly
mmm-hmm yeah yeah so it was just the
typical challenges but mindset was quite
big there and early on then yeah yeah
had to be yet to the outside world it
was never I was doing well but if people
back home would ask you know how you
getting on I just say you know it's
tough and it did sort be left at that
you know if I need a therapist if I told
you was you surrounded by and big
Billy's at the start yeah one of my
manager at the time was a really good
biller and he was more contract focused
and he was a was he lead team leads yeah
but he was purely [ __ ] now he was
focused on on billing so he would give
he would do the training when you
provide support but you can't blame him
when he's not got much around him and
he's been so successful biller he's got
to focus on that and so I had him around
me and somebody else that was on my team
she was probably six seven months ahead
of me I think she'd been there a bit
longer and she started to see results so
someone who was only billing about at 60
K someone who was doing more than 50
yeah I was seeing here reserved how do
you how do you think it's interesting I
think I saw a video and recently around
like well is it I think well how did you
word it was really good is like you can
own you can you can own you can't be
what you can't see
yeah I think that's really interesting
in that like because I think there's a
lot of people like again this is great
thing about the podcast where they can
go they may think that then building 100
K is like really really really decent
and they here with someone in the same
markets been in 200 or whatever and this
long [ __ ] actually that's actually
realistic or that's actually achievable
you know I mean yes how do you think how
do you think being around that impact to
do I do anything oh it was good but at
the same time again made because of the
big green little bit naive mainly cuz
it's probably my fault but because both
of the people that I looked up to or
both contract our newsroom poem yes it
was it was almost like I know he's still
relatable to a degree because I tu no
permit contractors over different
there's a lot of similarities in terms
of you know you work at the speed you
want to work and you can move a client
along as quickly as a contract if you
work in probably but at the time I just
couldn't see I couldn't see the life of
the you know the light the end of the
tunnel in terms of these guys a contract
and earning a decent amount and I'm on
perm just picking up some scrap so I
didn't have them friend I didn't have
somebody above that I could literally go
how are you doing it explained to me how
you
these perm rods how we control these
candidates how are you working
consulting clients I didn't have that as
much yeah
so I'm not sure how much of an effect
but that's interesting yeah how so when
did it start clicking for you then you
say it would probably say it properly
started clicking probably after about
year two in terms of sort of Billings
sort of hitting Seanie consultants
understand I'm billing ya behaviors well
you've got a sort of not you've got a
lock sort of 90 K over six months for
example you've changed it a bit now yeah
but that was one of the criteria so it
was at that stage of the foot okay so
the end of year two yeah sort of end of
year to start of start of year three
so the first 1215 months are quite
difficult and then I started to build
momentum and then by the time it started
to click so you know a lot longer
journey than most people have 12 months
then it suddenly clicks or how you
obviously would create a management
people in your team now how old long do
you typically give people would you say
I would how would your advice be to be
like look Shawn if you keep doing this
for the next 12-18 months trust me
good chances in the payoff what's the
typical without coming across as a
little bit with the things that went
wrong for me I try and make sure they
they aren't instilled in other people so
I've got a team obviously 11 now where
they are all are all perm we've got some
good people within that team as well
I've got a good structure so these I
definitely tell people to give me at
least 12 to sort of 15 8 18 months you
will start to see major returns and I
would hope month one sits well they do a
lot better than why I did but you know
we're looking to get these guys to sort
of 100k 150 K and beyond as quickly as
possible but as long as they want it in
can see it's gonna happen then yeah okay
so yeah obviously can't attend the year
- because you can't senior consultants
oh that does that just mean then yeah
that you're you didn't have any
management and responsibilities and when
did you start managing people I started
managing people so what senior
consultant
surrender year to start year free there
about a year in a senior role and then
it was a principal lead consultant role
again not really manage anybody it was
that it was a lead consultant that I
started to flourish just sat there in a
corner on my own billing picking on
George now just you know comparisons
what I've done in the past I was pretty
happy with that year and then the
age-old luck happens a lot of lots of
firms someone leaves a team lead role on
the other side of they'll the end of the
office yes I get pulled into a meeting
room Shirl I think he's good for you
next step if you were gone gone sit in
that seat and start to manage and look
after that team I have ambitions to
manage okay did you hear did you want
yeah of course but I'd spent a year yeah
a months of being a bit of a lone wolf
sat with another one lads who's now on
my team and we would just work quite
independently of the rest of the yeah
yes how did that happen then why did you
start doing that what were just like how
did you end up just like yeah just sort
of you to just smash now it just clicks
when it is confidence is there when you
realize something works and you can say
something with conviction it it just
clicks and all the songs you know The
Seeker isn't it you know you project to
the universe and it comes back and
clearly during that period it was
nothing but good yeah and the good vibes
you got to a point where you bill out
confidence starts build up a network and
and you and whoever it was just was
smashing out in the corner just doing
your thing yeah left your own device
much out left around devices from
management point of view we were coming
in where the placement or two a week you
know as well place one or two week yeah
for a period of time it was really it
was like for a better then it was by no
means was it unbelievable but my best
year was just over sort of two to sixty
so lot may come on bro that's not that's
good
not like compared to some of the guys
that are in our
organization but for me for someone had
been on such a journey of I was I was
living life and don't get me wrong
during that period I was I was still
working some lower level stuff so if I
go back to doing that now the level of
roles I would work would be much greater
so I would back myself as it were cuz I
was still picking up so yes not a volume
of placement she would have made if you
go back there now you would probably
result in the great buildings because
you would yes good yeah okay let's just
let you talk about that for a sec and
then we'll learn let's definitely dive
into sort of the management experience
was I think now that's where a lot of
people can get value so like firstly I
get questions all the time around he
Shem I'm at 150 mark 180 mark I just a
convert this to him to came on like how
what was that experience for you then
like was it grew up was it a graduate
let's just break that down a bit like
what like was it a gradual sort of
increase in sort of your performance or
was it yeah I would say what I it would
have been around I hear a bit like the
listeners out of here about 180 a couple
of times and instead of an okay money
you think okay but I've said you know
these guys around me and and the other
offices of doing this I've got a start I
need to find seven ck+ from somewhere
and it was just about being liberal
ruthless with who I've worked you know
but back then we still work that was all
on contingency as well there was no
retained business in there and you know
I didn't know were trained business was
and three or four years ago or
contingent just ratting around with
everybody else
yeah it's just a case of hang on I've
got to start so I'm gonna start to build
a better relationship with my clients
rather than it just to be a transaction
if you need a position feeling cold give
it to me you know and now we've got a
relationship still give me the job you
know are more meetings more relationship
building mmm
you open up more opportunities you know
you'll hear it today on the sales floor
you know if these guys will give me a
job if they've got one I got on well
with them you know have you unlocked
everything within that organization
probably not so I took the mentality
I've right I want more
is this everything you could be giving
me or rather other roles in other
sectors and you tend to find that a lot
of organizations were so on didn't know
you did that so I just opened up
companies more yeah well where did that
come from there was there a strategy
behind if I'm honest what in one of the
organization's I was who one of my best
clients I found out when I was doing a
little bit of candidate work that they'd
hired a small project of people from
another agency so yeah just just a bit
less slap in the face right I mean all
their jobs exactly and so yeah mmm so so
okay so so it was you you yet had a
couple years where you hit just under
200 and then it was right actually okay
so where where can I get sort of another
sending K out of out of my desk and I'll
see typically that can always leaders
been all right I need more new clients
morning clients well actually it's like
well actually so if I've got 1015 really
good clients am i doing everything that
I can
well that's quite so I guess some really
good advice in there is in light right
so right now yeah be honest with
yourself like have you got a real
understanding of their full hiring needs
or are you just yeah do they just think
that you can just help with this pocket
of that's it that's interesting because
it will see a lot of people will think
that they have to go out and win more
business rather than expand the clients
that them relations already have do you
know I mean exactly and if you're if
you're expanding the clients you have
and you're if you've been a bit of that
sort of level of relationship mmm you
know they know people is what you know
you don't it's not always about going
out and winning things wise at new
clients say open up what you've got see
you know that they go we get a lot of
referrals now from our clients clients
as well choosing the level of service we
provide
yeah so we're getting more and more
roles come in that way yeah it's just
about opening up what you've got have a
look at that first before you move yeah
better like would you tell you guys now
then when you're talking some about okay
like do you feel do you feel like you
don't you feel like again as much how
that client where they should possible
like how how do you encourage people to
think or approach expanding accounts
just just ask this age-old ask questions
you don't want to hear the answer - or
even if you think that's big that one
course even if you know even if you the
the the response is they will I know my
client that's that's completely fine can
you just come and ask the question
though mm-hmm that's the question and if
the response is the same great let me
know you know happy days is it work but
just go and ask questions you don't want
to hear the answers to because you'll
find either not them if the answers you
don't want to hear yeah they are the
ones you meet here and normally they're
not as bad here from with that I love
that advice I remember again I advised
myself I had a few like just [ __ ] things
happen when candidates nose and I
remember hearing that voice I was like
that's exactly what needs to be doing
asking the question you don't hear the
answer to and you'd taken account for
the process and stuff like that but in
terms of an expanding climb
relationships context what you sound
like
and how many other jobs have your I
don't know like what would you know and
I hear it's just a case of you know it's
all about social service level agreement
the offering the solution we offer we've
done very well within this area I see
you've got this airing this air how come
what do we need to do to and our service
offering it's not sort of it or you know
you you're looking a pipeline and so
you're looking at the their attention
there you try to open it up that way
really okay
and if an ask that you can contribute
need to hear those sorts of figures
considered previously just stronger on
my Candida site and the ability to to
work with candidates I was gonna say
these were control but yeah well you
control more of the product like you
fellow you had more control manage over
the process yeah well you know someone's
on the open market they say the 150k you
get into or free interview stages and
then it's off for time and they've
already got you know the rough stage of
the other people that 50 K become 60 K
because the markets allowed them is that
you know if you if you're talking to a
candidate at the start of the process
and you know you then you're you're
vetting them heavily against the role
and then you're going every time you
speak for that individual you're reading
the reasons why they're looking to leave
them nice work
what time yeahjust every state sorry
qualification of that candidate well
what was what was the market like the
usual cream and how difficult and
channel was any challenges at the can
the Bach niche net Microsoft's there was
more there was more candidates than the
word jobs and then when I moved I really
support the to a degree yeah I mean the
the let the quality of Canada wasn't
necessarily always there but you know
we're talking about times where a lot of
companies were tightening their belts
and then when I moved over to the
infrastructure side when I started to do
well and yeah there's an abundance of
candidates in that market you know two
three years on companies has started
hiring pretty heavily again so yeah how
how did you how did you find the
transition and change in slight focus
and Marquette he was pretty seamless
really really and I'm a big believer in
understanding what you call recruiting
for understands your marketplace
understand the technologies understand
you know the frustrations the hiring
managers have so but just spend a
weekend a couple of weeks whatever it
was or a couple of weekends sorry just
understanding my marketplace and
competing technologies yeah how was your
going about I just simple Google job or
conversations Google Wikipedia looking
at forums trying to contribute to a
couple of forums on LinkedIn as well
just sort of asking questions just
trying to be inquisitive over market
really oh no no one you know if I'm
going to recruit in the certain space I
want to know what I'm recruiting for
because of course better engagement how
did you get your people to start
learning about their market now those
things are the will get them to you know
sort of presentation in a couple of the
week in within a couple of weeks that
our yeah which outlines their entire
market the technologies they work that
we've got to work on and that's a tip
and the training they'll do will be you
know obviously Wikipedia Google get them
to look at a few videos as well and
things like that just to destroy them so
they can understand what they're
recruiting
monster what is that where do you think
that fit in between in that sort of
process of you doing
well and really starting to build a lot
of confidence and up in your performance
how do you think your mindset changed or
how did your mindset look like that
stage I started to believe really and I
think that's the big thing for me when
I'm almost quite like I'm sort of a bit
of a contradiction when I first came
into recruitment I didn't want to be a
failure but because I couldn't see the
earning potential even though it was
there in front of me you know the emails
are coming around with people 10 12 13
grands before tax
you know then throw the basic on the
other sort of emails were coming around
all the time but I couldn't see that I
was going to get there and I suppose the
mindset in terms of I'm guessing I
didn't believe that it was in touching
distance in me so when I started to do
when I started to fly a yeah the mindset
changed I believed and I think that's
the main thing and recruitment mmm
believing in yourself
yeah believe in yourself and believing
you can get there we know recruitments a
lucrative industry we know it can change
people's lines and the types remember
that though and early on when you're
just [ __ ] everything yeah of course
oh yeah how do you solve I guess that's
part of your job now isn't it to make
people understand that that is and they
can reach that light as quickly as
possible that they need to believe that
stuff like that yeah anyone that comes
onto my team or within the business
understands it typically a first 12
months you know the worst 12 months
you'll have and recruitment you'll work
harder for very you know very little
reward in some cases but it gets easier
it's the job where if you put in the
graft from the start you put in the
right level of graft in a you know work
smart as well each year that goes by it
gets a lot easier so you clearly have
always been exposed and around sort of
some high performers then in the like
anything that you've always picked up on
those sorts of people don't because
clearly you really started to get
yourself in a mixer and but there's
always still people that use this
obviously aspiring to try and be or
being in in that sort of area of where
the other people are in the business
like anything that you picked up on that
was just
work smart work hard and work quickly
and be prepared to put in well at that
time my talk was just be fair to put in
the ground
yeah the graph the hours if needs be
there's some of the best when I look
back to when I first started some of the
guys that were doing believably well
were the ones that if something did come
in they would drop what they had on and
they would stay and they would they
would work it box it off and then they
would move on to the next
appreciate recruitments changed a lot
since sort of the boiler room data then
and before I'm sure it's just the
ability to work FX still stands out in
that yeah of course I you know if you
take pick up a good brief from a client
you should be looking at as looking at
it obviously is what you need to do but
also this is this is my my next meal
ticket you know I need to do this to the
best of my ability let's get this sorted
quickly and let's move on to the next
yeah I don't see the news people for
years you'd hear that you know someone
would come in for an interview and if
they worked in a call center sales call
center you know they used to volume in
the used to working quickly it always be
yep
they're good for subcontract they
wouldn't be good for perm which is more
process driven but I were a team of
individuals that I teach to act if you
know what that you know you're there to
provide a service you're there to help
this client out but let's work quickly
if he's not at this individualism
willing to work to our sort of pace then
somebody else works it's a highly
competitive market it sounds simple that
but you be yeah like you'd be surprised
at how much of analyze actually gives
you if you're willing to just have a bit
of an urgency around being their own
recruiter I do not mean I've had that a
couple of times where people gone from
contract to perm and they've said that
they've really applied that same urgency
to the sort of perm way that they're
delivering perm and recruitment and it's
really helped and the hundreds and can
give you an advantage do not mean it
sounds simple but and okay cool so ended
up then so did you know when you moved
over in that person left the team leads
you then inherit a team
yeah inherited a team of three people
was that like obviously normally the
typical route
is yeah yeah you solve typically end up
managing the people that you may have
obviously been on the similar journey
we've all been around for a little while
and then it's like sure enough it would
be great you manage them but do not I
mean it's it's free for people I'm
assuming you didn't I yeah it was sat
next day so though we were to know more
so for me Tim's then reporting to me but
it took that well I took on you know the
other three people and just sort of sat
in the boardroom with them and just went
right it's I'm sat with you boys now
it's um it's time to sort of try and
turn this around and they are not doing
very well not not particularly okay very
there was everyone was a little bit
green in that team I can't remember sort
the level of expertise it was no one
that had been there for a period of time
so yeah II was going into that with some
work needs to be done yeah really
yeah and what and then what what marker
was this it was IT so free of the guys
the development cross java.net pitch
alright always he always do itv yeah
okay so what what went on in that period
there mate so how long did you manage
that team for that that sort of the team
in truth I probably sat there for three
or four months and for right I've got a
continued billing bow can I get these
lot how can I get these lot sort of
performing to sort of a decent level I
was still a lead at that point you've
always got a walk the shoe you know walk
the walk were you giving the job title
so I found it really tough you know
I'd gone from I mean absolutely no
confidence in recruitment
he's scrapping away it's a sort of 12 15
16 months two years of it being good so
then now my next job I back to the
bottom I go just just sort of a little
bit like well I know what I need to do
but how do i project that into others
and how can I make them sustainable
self sustainable while I continue to hit
the same level so I found it really
tough to start with
luckily what was in my challenging
partner just getting everybody on the
same page and there's a lot there was
some sort of there were some bad traits
within some of these guys just in terms
of the habits they picked up maybe they
dropped me manage particularly well
immediate yeah it was just a team that
needed me have an arm put around it and
a little bit of a push to get them to
start doing what they needed to do but I
managed to get them online on a
reasonable level and then we just
started to fill in we started to hire
more around them visiting now yeah so I
think I grew that team to about six
within sort of the first year and then
bear in mind I had no management
experience and I'm quite direct at the
time yeah you just in terms of I'd give
you feedback II Beth Scott I've done
some well they got remember a lot of
these a lot of what these lads were
working on was sort of my clients as
well cuz I in this and a certain I
worked the certain disciplines have fell
outside of my discipline regardless of
him fit was my client or not I'd have to
pass it so I had additional stresses of
I'm giving you deal reputation I'm
giving you something to work I've also
got to manage you and try and build you
up but at the same time I'm really
concerned about the level of output of
what you're you're giving me back so
he's got my name on the emails and the
phone calls that go in so we built it to
about 6 we then dropped it to about four
a couple of people unfortunately fell by
the wayside and then yeah we've been
sort of slowly growing sort of up and
down and now sort of a head count of 11
okay and how long it takes or how long
is that little journey that has taken me
two years two years okay so that let's
just talk about that first year then
how how much of an impact did your
Billings yeah how much of an impact did
your Billings take first year it would I
think it about about 200 mmm cuz I think
that that's that think what people some
people be thinking might light manage
them in that seemed like the logical
step but how how much are my Billings
gonna drum yeah I mean it's like the
long game it's the longer yeah yeah is
that what kept you sort of kept going
that I just thought that I'm not I
haven't got the sustainability for me
personally to continue billing and I
wanted to long I'm on talking yeah long
to the future and and I like I've sort
of evolved as a person I wanted to
challenge myself so weight evolved is
just I think I've become more hungry
more I'm I suppose when the light switch
came on a site doing when I'm
recruitment it sort of switched on
everything for me really and yeah I'm
just a lot more driven now I'm a lot
more the resilience and the mental
strength or you're like you're like
fully committed to this movement
yeah by to start with it was just gonna
work yeah work it all I'm science went a
little bit more its get a bit better all
that good yeah I believe now yeah and
and then now you really tell we do
seriously it's just like right now I
want to make the much my status as
possible absolutely in the first few
years I'd I'm not sure if I took it not
seriously is probably the wrong word I
don't think I know he's me in jail right
and yeah taking that team I what dropped
about 50 grand in Billings or 60 grand
in Billings and and yeah it was tough a
long-term I could see the goal I could
see especially I could see some sprouts
where some of the guys were starting to
get it in a couple of my new recruits
we're starting to get the vision and the
culture that we're trying to implement
how did you how did you start getting
these people to the point where you were
sort of happy light and not see a lot
how that what was that process like as
you said you had no management
experience so that what are some of the
things that you start to focus on first
so you just mentioned they're lined line
vision or that like how how did you
start approaching getting these people
because I'm sure you just learn along
the way and mistakes and all that yeah
looking back now how what are some of
the things that you ended up focusing on
more I think I
you know I've hired these guys or people
so I've gotta put some trust into them
so when they were coming to me we
slightly new ideas at the start or
slightly new ways of looking at things I
sort of listen
whereas before you might find out yeah
in a case of you know sort of way back
when we were heavily KPI focus you know
caught screens on the board of four
hours a day hundred twenty dollars not
the rest of it and they were starting to
come to new approaches with me when I
took us of the new challenge so it's
about sort of listening to what they've
got repackaging it and basically and
laying on sort of new people so in terms
of you know less lesson look at
qualification around the positions were
pulling that the individuals were
working with are we going out to meet
them are we going out to meet you know
just the nuts and bolts of recruitment
and I stripped it right back and just
try to implement very simple mmm but the
third the first thing then was actually
being willing to listen yes obviously
you got before you got that point you as
you said bit of a loan more if you knew
what you needed to do yeah to get what
you wanted right
yes I mean so like why would you not
then that's the typical thing that
happens because you're challenging right
you then why would you not then blot
look guys look so if we do this there's
a very good chance that when we hit the
numbers of your wanted you know I mean
it's not as simple as that
no especially you stick the framework of
right these KPIs and try and attach it
to every different market and it just
doesn't work you know in there in the
support market or the info is all about
high numbers it is because that's what
that market sort of dictate like test
market I was asking people with like.net
in PHP especially an open source and
Java to try and hit some of these big
numbers and actually you don't need that
in this market that have the reverse
effect of light then sort of being like
[ __ ] on what no chance of hitting this
which damaged the motivation or no
because they try to do it it was when I
realized the the quality okay they
wanted to you but the quality against
the framework wasn't working and when we
started to turn and scrape it back and
look at what was needed mmm that he
basically click for two of the lads
from that point we just sort of
influence right your market would
typically dips how you need to sort of
your plan your week around this and this
you know you would try and help that
individual into a market so I suppose
just adapting each person to what near
the working I'm really well how does how
does then managing and adapting your
management of style these people have
what's been your journey with that
that's been interested about you know I
mean yeah so I've gone from being quite
direct I mean I'm still still quite an
element of that but I've gone from to
what yeah you said earlier like good or
bad feedback straight at their desks on
the phone yeah when people would be
giving people give you the story and
it's like you know nice give me the
question and I last for the battery and
you know if lost lost a couple of people
through the wire and along the way and
they provided feedback in terms of maybe
sort of the scott stiles clash there's a
little bit of self reflection from me
yeah how hard is it to take that i
agreed with what one one of the
individuals that gave me a little bit of
feedback it wasn't there's any sort of
yeah probably about a year ago eight
months ago and she gave me some feedback
and it's about okay okay maybe a little
bit too direct
okay the sort of the level of temper
that's required to work a per market in
my eyes didn't quite see and yeah so i I
reflected on what was said and I took on
board you've got to evolve from ya know
two years into sort of legal team
managing a team so know exactly so
listening to what as long as I agree
with what's being said in terms of oh
you might have a point I'll take it on
board and try and evolve and try and
adapt a lot to think that's got me to
where I am now so I think there's a lot
of said in eyes that just becoming more
more willing to take that on the chin
and go right you know what fair enough
and then instead of just letting go in
one ear and out the other
yeah and likewise other like feedback
sessions with sort of certainly then
with my team in terms of you know when
I'm doing their reviews when the last
questions old of us would have been and
how am I getting on in your eyes what
for me how why do you actually look
yeah looking for it again you take the
feedback probably don't give a lot back
wait until they've left the room and
then yeah digest it a little bit Alan
so Howell and then how what's been your
sort of journaling experience in getting
better at managing your time a typical
challenge for a lot of building managers
is sort of having enough time to make
billing and then also have enough time
to manage the people like what's been
your sort of experience generally that
view that was tough that periods of when
I became a team leader and I had five or
six underneath me at that point where
the emphasis was on me to sort of
officially run that team was more
accountable that was difficult because
you're trying to help these individuals
will maintain your billing and he took
me ages to realize that again trust the
people around you I've employed these
people but for a reason I've trained
these individuals up you know that
they've done the nuts and bolts of the
role if they ask question just ask it
you know it's not rocket science we just
ask it back to them what do you think
I'm not reinventing the wheel but it's
not inside just an insight and if you
ask the question and you know what do
you think and they don't give you the
right one back then you help if not yeah
so like encouraging people more is this
comment quite a bit recently where like
you're yeah you become aware that you
didn't want a bit of common like the
comfort blanket where it's like Sean
what do you think this what do you think
I should do and become rather than help
them encourage them to come to the
destination and place themselves right
and then and then did I did that then
mean that you was then getting pulled
put it suppose less because yeah yeah
should your day yeah as a person you've
got to how well how did your day
typically let then as you're managing
these people it would be when I was a
building manager it depends what was on
my desk on the day but it'll either be I
was or was that that as a recruiter you
know they been looking to just Paul
Rowles or monkey meetings both myself
and my team or you know been some
resourcing Orton but the day typically
would be split between BD candidates and
in intervals looking after the team and
obviously if they came to me during that
period then I'll deal with it
not believer in you can only come into
my desk yeah time I think that that's
about it's the wrong culture for me
really yeah well it's been your
experience in hiring the type of people
that you want in your team that's always
a challenge for people are hiring good
people for their team have you got
better that again just don't high with
you go you guys know is if you've got
your gut instinct just don't just rely
on that it's not because you were
recruiters were typically good at
typically good at a job but we're
terrible at recruiting for our team as
an ER we we sort of go off gut instinct
you know someone you know someone walks
into the meeting we're back at the
reading room but they walk there quickly
yes no you know do they look presentable
you know are we going quite well they've
got similar hobbies or although they've
got some sales experience here you just
you start to bounce around you sort
create this picture of an individual and
then they start four weeks I'm pretty
different nice it's about a little more
work so how have you made it we've just
got a framework in pray in place now
where we are asking about you know can
can you show us sort of different times
where or give examples of when you've
shown resilience or when you've changed
someone's much just more basic sort of
sales related questions but it gives us
a framework about to okay and we're also
throwing a few there in there that are a
little bit different purely to to show a
bit of you know mental agility this job
is all about me just tell me something
about tell me something about you that's
not on your CV you know it's it's a lot
people its finger on their feet yeah
tell me something I don't know
you know it can't be on this on this to
sheet piece of paper yeah a few then
what what's become better for you for
you is that less so then let's have a
conversation and see how it goes see if
we get on for it like yeah that got nice
things is you've actually put together a
bit of a real clean framework and
process where if they demonstrate the
right qualities against these particular
things and there's a good chance that
they're going to do well war yeah
he's not rocky sorry yeah not
reinventing the wheel but I do think
that a lot recruitment companies and
you'll be surprised how many people
don't have a framework or some sort of
clean process the key things that you
always look out for ask for word you
know I mean yeah and if you do that you
are gonna hire the same caliber of
individual each time you like to think
rather than just going off like what we
said you know I quite like that person
you know that person comes well they're
non-negotiable for you now then when
you're hiring for your team they have to
have or people have to have I like
mental agility I like what that can can
think on their feet I don't care what
what the discussion is I like people
that can turn can contain a phrase or
can give a response I like people that
are resilient
brazillian some real mental strength in
there I also like people that genuinely
want it and there's a reason for them
coming to work every day you know not
not just to buy a new car I don't get a
car and final little bit about real
reasons like you know you've got two
kids to support or yeah I mean money to
buy I like people to have a real reason
to come to work because they'll
typically get where they need to be much
quicker yeah because this is real drive
behind there but also when they do they
are at the stage where they believe they
can make money because they are um
they're going to want to stay there and
they're going to enjoy it more so that
the sort of keeping some mental agility
resilient nice so I haven't been billing
now for I saw that long something about
put about six months how's that
transition been initially it was scary
really well you've gone from controlling
what you weren't for degreaser yeah
absolutely not but yeah it's good it's
good I had a couple of months where the
sort of senior team around me management
have helped me with some coping
strategies and mechanisms to be able to
to control what I do on a day-to-day so
what's the what's the what's the
objective you're on now then if you're
not to improve GP beheads
and to grow a team to be percent
successful around that really and then
what and now you'd what do you have
targets around those things yeah
yeah so yeah that is complete
especially when yeah especially when you
look at certain positions you think I
would have minded that if I was real
crew yeah how do you deal with that like
you said coping mechanisms there let's
talk a bit about because people will
need the light that people will want
those or I'll be thinking about I need
to encode from that because mechanisms
or whatever like what are some of the
things that help you free that this in
that just having someone to act as the
soundboard someone's you know sit the
other side of a desk or go for a coffee
with who will just listen to you for
five seven minutes and then so how do
you think um do you think I'm doing this
while yeah this has happened all that's
happened or this is how do you approach
it yeah and and and it's just like what
my team do to me if they ask the
question and then I you know ask what do
they think think they give me yeah yeah
my managers don't need he's only doing
the same thing to me but it was yeah and
so I have that as coping mechanism is a
obviously someone in the business yeah
yeah he's yeah he's worked really been
why you haven't sort of what the path
meant alright yeah these you know things
aren't always too bad look at this and
look at that so it's it's just about
taking a step back breathing and
realizing you know we're not in a bad
place what if we're doing pretty well
that you knew when you use not you're
not control or anything you know you can
be even more hard than yourself yeah
definitely um you carry the way at the
world and the shoulders yeah but nice
good really good I'm enjoying it you're
gonna yeah massively massively odd I get
so much joy now which like from seeing
other people do well Yes Mother
where does that come from when does it
when do I get in the morning and look at
people's figures and then start talking
to them about the next incentive sign
you know you're only this way or I
genuinely get excited when so where does
I can fly the old me when I was on the
transitional periods or or when I was
doing well on my own if I see someone
doing a little bit better than me
there's a little bit of jealousy there
yeah
good jealousy yeah and now it's someone
within the team do something well or
even some wider business I'm generally
happy for them I don't I don't know
where that comes from but yeah why seems
like in the right job then if asked
yeah couple of things a couple of things
on on that med before us you cop things
on resilience and as we wrap up and like
now as you like clearly then you've been
on a UB just been really honest with
your sort of management journey like
what what are some of the things that
you've that you've done or also you
consistently do now that you think of a
really enabled you to sort of empower
your team to get the best out of them
and not obviously still an ongoing
journey but just for those listen that
are managing and obviously it's a
constant battle process or trying to get
the most out of your team but what are
some of the sort of things that you've
seen or you've done and being part of
that you feel like has really empowered
the people around your new thing trust
them trust them more give them more
response in you start trusting people
more I think you just have an open
conversation with people in you know a
one-to-one basis and sort of gauge gauge
where they are in their journey with the
role and if they wants if they want to
be part if they want to be part of
something you can you can get that vibe
you've shown interest that's outside of
what they're doing and outside of what
they're doing and the wider business
yeah it just starts a conversation and
then you sort of learn who needs who
needs support who doesn't need support
who needs an arm round put an arm around
them who needs in it all sort of kick
off the back side from time to time
mmm it just starts with a conversation
and then once you learn to trust people
you can then empower them then they they
starts to do you know you have champions
within your team and they starts to do
your role for you almost make yourself
redundant if you can do it well enough
yeah so you think it all starts with
really starting to breed trusted people
and yeah once once the training process
is through once they're you know they've
been given the call that they're capable
of doing their job and they're capable
of taking advice and capable of sort of
delivering to a certain degree and you
start feeding in more responsibilities
and more sort of trust points hmm that
just cultivates such a team mentality
and coaches a big element as well you
know you can some teams they are a set
of line wolves and that is I wouldn't
want to manage me
far worse at around four or five people
back then because you warned everybody
to be involved in everybody's business
and everybody to be championing each
other collaborative yeah without doubt
because positivity spreads and while
someone was sat there at the moment or
the list of listen there might be
thinking well I don't care what you know
the person next to me does it's all
about me that doesn't directly affect my
buildings but if you've got a desk
that's or a bank that's bouncing and
everyone's happy and everyone's the
productivity is up people are selling
not only their services for the roles
that they want but it goes back to
opening up accounts you know but the
people next to you are now selling into
clients are trying to pull you roles
what do you think that you've seen
you've seen a lot in yeah making more of
a collaborative environment well I
definitely definitely have you can't
kind of like that anything if I'm being
completely honest I don't know something
I'll just install into everybody you
know what so you communicate it to
people early that look this this is
obviously you have your own individual
but the this is this we're a team and
I'm assuming you communicate out quite
early yeah I suppose that when I was
doing well if somebody was that's the
less than somebody who sat to the right
to me
no matter how much good news I had I
wouldn't be that sort of person to
openly go above and beyond shouting and
yes wolf of Wall Street type because I
was very aware that the two individuals
next to me might be having a bit of a
[ __ ] I've been there they don't
necessarily want to see me jumping up
and down going you know going over the
chair so I have cultivates that see when
we celebrate everybody's yeah I like
that last wing before an awesome
question around resilience what what are
some of the common things that you've
seen in the people that you've managed
and managing now the ething sort of can
that holds them back on really hitting
that peak performance anything that you
picked up their belief really belief no
matter what no matter what people say or
think I truly believe that there's a gap
between when you first start
and so when you even start performing to
a semi
reasonable level there's an elephant of
belief of am I am I going to get there
this seems a bit a bit of a reach you're
going to a new recruitment firm and it's
the big the best builders are doing well
they've been there for quite a while so
luckily in our office and in our
organization we've got a few new people
that have started I've said within the
course of a year who are doing very well
and you actually find that that that
creates a different culture because the
new people that got new recruits are
Queens the organization I've seen these
people that aren't too far away from
them very well so I think belief is
clear yeah no it's true it's like when
you when you're a Korea and you truly
believe that when you when you speak to
a client candidate that you truly
believe you're the best person they
should be speaking to
that's just so powerful to really truly
believe and then body and have that
mindset you know I mean that is the game
changer and all right couple questions
around resilience mate and then I'm
gonna I'll shoot the final question all
right so first one what what is
resilience in recruitment mean to you
sticking out being prepared sir to rob
your sleeves up and guess look in mmm
you're gonna you know you faced in a
you're in an environment you find
yourself in an environment even if you
you good at what your job sixty percent
of the time people are going to say no
or put the phone down or you know shut
that door so it's about just being the
best version of yourself
mmm every stage of every call and just
driving that forward and being prepared
to just just keep important one foot in
front of the other that you've been in
for a while so like how how has the
importance or need for resilience
changed as the industries of old you
think it still required back when I
started it was purely as I think I said
at the start of this piece it was purely
hard work your hard work
now resilience it comes in slightly
different forms you've got to be
creative and how you approach the market
and what you do mmm so he's still there
heavily but I think it's just you've got
to be a little bit just right right yeah
okay and then what and this is
something you have to do I guess what
what can people do themselves to instill
more resilience in themselves and also
what can people do themselves to instill
resilience in their teams I would say
just be open things like podcast
gentleman I do some reading look at look
at other instances where people have
been down and out and have succeeded and
just just widen widen your horizons that
way really it's bad
yeah perspective massive its massive for
me he's helped me go from being a
nervous wreck with the team thinking how
am I gonna how am I gonna sort of you
know control iron so actually I've got
to trust these guys mm-hmm so that's
what I would say so yeah cultivate
people to yeah look look out learn and
not get me and so before I should have
final question what what is a Shawntel
you excited about twenty to twenty
million going on you hiring for you team
yeah hard and always on the lookout for
a strong individual yeah but we are
hiring in your LinkedIn imagine 2020
how's it looking at being excited about
yeah and I good and we won team of the
year last year some pretty heavy team so
it's down to sort of money brought into
the business and sort of new money
brought into the businesses we're not
sort of existing contractors so an
affordance you do man come on we did
just over a million really and that was
how many of you biz that was about about
six to seven if you really a few rookies
in there that's all we're just
resourcing but yeah six
yeah no good really good AdWords so how
does that work out I really is that how
you do it like every G people ahead yeah
head counts vanity it's all about sort
of yeah it's all about what was that
then they is 1112 grand versing grandpa
heads
and for a period of time it's yeah it's
nice it's good it's good Congrats man
I'll say this is you and a big
organization as well as a lot of people
in that business so to sort of win
accolades like that that's no joke right
it's a real achievement not from where
the perm team's been it's really proud
of that really proud yeah really good
love that so final question me yeah if
if Sean could communicate to every
single recruiter out there they'd listen
they take on your advice I'd implement
it tomorrow what would Sean that be
saying to the people what comes to my my
peace to anyone listening would be just
continue to put one foot in front of the
other stay in there and consult about
your candidate and client you know don't
be yes-man or one and just offer the
best service you can just stay in there
it it comes it comes in the end Sean
it's been a pleasure man coach
cheers mate thank you